we'll get started in five psych i'm
gonna take the intro on this one
welcome to the last word episode number
178 and we are here around the campfire
for the last time in 2021 and what a
year it has been ps5 and xbox one xbox
series x turned one years old the thing
that shall not be named is starting its
third year
and we didn't actually have a major
destiny expansion this year which is
weird to say
that doesn't mean it's been a quiet year
in the franchise and to some it may have
been the best year yet but before we
talk about that we are very lucky to be
able to chat with everyone who is here
for the live chat who listens through
itunes or spotify or any audio platform
as you take us on the go or on youtube
in the following days thank you all so
much for being with us for so many
episodes and making it honestly our
biggest year yet shout out to vagabondo
for the super chat as well thank you
very much for being both naughty and
nice right in the middle of the intro
you're welcome buddy you earned it
i also want to take a second to thank
our newest host this man has had an
amazing year reviewing mini games for
ign we are all sorry for nerf legends
though we are sorry
joining us joining the exclusive club of
hosts for fire team chat
got to see a new fast and furious movie
this year and really has succeeded on so
many fronts personal commercial and just
everywhere that we know him on and yet
somehow made time during the second half
of the year to join the campfire of the
last word as a permanent host thank you
sir for the fun that you bring the hot
takes that keeps things very spicy and
even your long running segments very
lucky to have you join us and thank you
for all these chats but not to be
outdone
my co-host ninja incognito and now
member of last stand media
this man was on a thousand podcasts this
year or at least it feels like it and
and then he was called up to the majors
when he filled some huge shoes and
joined defining duke as a co-host with
lord manny plays if you haven't listened
to him chat about xbox even if you
prefer the other box you are missing out
on some great discussions and because
that wasn't enough he decided to follow
in the ways of the zuck and is now part
of the meta well kinda he is now part of
the oculus team who will take us into
the vr future so we can end up like all
those people in wall-e
there's some irony though when a man who
is so anti-meta actually now has become
one with the meta in a matter of
speaking
but seriously congratulations to all of
your success this year and can't wait to
see what 2022 holds for you for travis
and myself so sappy enter out of the way
and let's jump into this episode how
have you been doing fellas oh
look at that
surprise we weren't even aware of this
i feel like we gotta do one for you
guys
stopped kickboxing this year so he could
spend more time with his
viewers on twitch yes yes uh
the man bishop's up the wazoo now he's
he's selling those those sugars what are
they yeah
uh yes and mobile games yeah as well
part of my sponsorships
outriders ambassador tremendous
tremendous channel growth um just to see
what's going on with him as he climbs he
ascends the destiny community ranks as
well you know also acknowledged by
bungie numerous times
and uh yeah just a great friend co-host
the immaculate one himself
bonus of the last word you know we do
well thank you gentlemen
um and shout out to gaming forte uh the
holidays are over i can lay back and
relax for the next 10 months until i
have to do it all over again thanks for
making my 21 21 better love you thank
you gaming forte for being here
vagabonde as well both of you guys
jumping and starting the super chats
early
uh so our goal with this episode so you
guys know depending on what you're
looking to listen to uh we want a
destiny 2 21 recap kind of go through
our thoughts on the seasons kind of hit
the high points see what sticks out to
us is big bad ugly and good uh and then
also our 2022 kind of predictions and
hopes for destiny as witch queen is
got a lot of weight on it so we will see
and then we've also got the second half
kind of want to do
our quick takes on just our top video
games of 2021 because this is not the
only thing that we play
and just kind of our most anticipated
for 2022 for us as well so that's kind
of the general rundown of what we are
going to be working on and
that intro stuff out of the way
uh gentlemen
no no
guests or anything just the three hosts
sitting around the campfire live chat
keeping us entertained as always if
travis doesn't manage to do it all the
time anyway yes
but yeah destiny 2 2021
no expansion this year and yet
you could maybe push beyond light into
this thing because you know
stasis pretty much lived all throughout
this year
[Laughter]
but we had beyond light season of the
hunt paired with that one had season of
the chosen kick us off towards the start
of the year season the splicer season of
the lost 30th anniversary a lot of
things happen this year um kind of
chronologically for you guys if we start
with beyond light a little bit of stasis
lc anna clovis exotics you've got lament
no time to explain cloud strike isaac's
tomorrow salvation's grip that's still
useless deep stone crypt that's been you
know one that many of us have seen and
even next gen 2 or next gen for destiny
2 kicked off with that plus we got a new
planet of europa
um that launched alongside season of the
hunt crow and spider story we actually
got to see
you know crow was brought back to life
then we got to see you know the first
teases of osiris what started there him
and spider zeba wrath was now mentioned
we had the crypto with hunts the lure
hawkmoon brought came back to the game
in the harbinger mission and the duality
exotic in the season pass that launched
just before 2020 ended but kind of took
us into what started 2021
um just for that piece alone those two
how did 2021 with destiny start for you
guys getting through the holidays the
donning was going on
about a year ago like it was now where
you guys where
looking back that far does it feel like
more than a year less than a year like
12 years later
it's funny yeah just listening to you
uh go through each line item it was kind
of like wow that yeah that happened and
that happened i think for me
i remember the trepidation coming in
with stasis like how is this gonna play
how's this gonna work and you know us
all talking about like
freezing guardians and in the crucible
how's that gonna feel remember that like
that was the big thing and i think we
all unanimously felt
that it's probably gonna have a problem
with the crucible
i think we all felt that we all saw that
one coming i like that one was not a
surprise you know the aramis campaign
the the ending and you know like well
the non-ending we know it's still you
know frozen so it's still going to come
around stuff but they did give a lot of
content they gave us a new subclass the
aspects i felt were cool
and when you list out the exotics i
thought no time to explain was strong
way stronger than i thought cloud strike
was really good just way too hard to get
eyes tomorrow rest in peace trav i i
know i know everything you've been
through the suffering you're gonna try
to get that one i was crazy lucky to get
that on the second thing but
to um ease point
you know with the whole
i mean actually uh
tassie's point tazzy they introduced the
i think quickly from wrong didn't they
introduce
target farming with raids in destiny 2
through deep stone
like interaction yeah yeah
yep the chest so i thought that was huge
for for the raid community because that
took us back to rapid machine and and i
i missed that which is like okay i want
the succession and let's be honest
there's some good perks there's some
really good perks the the refilling of
the ammo the reconstruction
recombination stuff was cool deep stone
crypt was was super solid y'all like i i
liked it a lot i mean the um the lullaby
was the theme of the the anthem for a
minute and yeah like you said next
generation two so oh look solid
not gonna go super crazy because super
season in the hunt was not it for me
personally like i was not about none of
that i mean i just liked the storyline
and we knew who ziva rapped was and and
uh what you call it um
you know crow comes back and we gotta we
go through that whole thing but even the
execution of that was whack at the end
because
oh we're freeing you it did he's still
sitting there for the rest of the season
yeah
so that's my overall announcement solid
not at the top level of a
forsaken or anything but it was solid
overall if you combine both of them or
if you look at season of the house by
itself yeah no but if you combine beyond
what it was okay but i'm curious what do
you guys think try what you think about
the distal section beyond light season
and hot
um
beyond light was last year
season the hunt was also last year yeah
but it's like that's what still started
the year yeah yeah so let's start season
the hunt started this year correct or
well i mean they launched at the same
time
yeah they launched at the same time it
was just like
january 1st 2021 that's still what we
were in the middle of that's kind of why
i started there
yeah yeah so it correct me if i'm wrong
is this the first year
uh that destiny hasn't had an expansion
since you started correct yeah correct
and that's if you don't include the 30th
anniversary of which i bet you bungee
would but i mean
system-wise you have to buy it as an
expansion like if you want to play the
30th anniversary on pc and xbox you got
to buy it twice but for everybody else
no it's not
it's uh yeah it's an add-on of cosmetics
and a dungeon and an exotic depending on
what you break down what you pay for but
still a lot of cool stuff in there but
yeah no no full-blown big story
expansion for sure
which is weird yeah
um yeah i'm kind of like cog i thought
season the hunt was kind of the weakest
one uh and by the time this year started
we had sort of run out of main content
and i believe
stasis was live and a well and crucible
just destroying things and yeah i think
i even said on fire team chat i probably
made myself look terrible i said uh when
we saw that first competitive clip and
people were getting frozen and then
killed i was like yeah i mean we're just
seeing eclipse i don't think that they'd
let you like actually fully free
somebody super easily and then just like
ruin crucible that just feels like they
wouldn't they wouldn't let that happen
surely they came out
yeah
we saw that like wow yeah hindsight's 20
20 on that one yeah
we all predicted yeah i mean everybody
everybody said that when they saw the
clip but i was just like i have a little
more faith in bungie than that and then
well and that was the thing is like we
all saw it and they even knew it they
knew because they had bumped it up so
many times and they're like well now we
can't completely break it but we do have
to knock it down but they said it came
in like five steps too high like they
even said that in interviews later in
this year so we know
yeah when it came in it was crucible was
hot i still hate my titan stasis like
i'm never i don't know if i'm ever gonna
love that subclass because
just kind of its general functionality
because the warlocks
and the hunters both have had some
really cool stuff and like titans have
had like bits and pieces but the general
functionality of the subclass i never
lean in it i've like i've done so many
different things this year with regards
to
like guides and things and the titan has
not i mean there's been warlock builds
for like grand masters and stuff hunters
still go in viz and still have you know
certain fun
titans just nobody's ever been like all
right now glacial quake yes this is the
thing you want no one has said that all
year since this thing launched and it
just hasn't changed so
yeah no it's been stasis is like it's
been a cool theoretical subclass for me
but i'm like they better do better and
the whatever comes next titans need to
feel a little better next time because
this year
i didn't honestly get all my aspects and
fragments until this season
wow
because i never played the class so like
that's actually there's two more i think
i haven't gotten that started during the
30th anniversary is that true they added
more i don't know if they added more or
they did them during season of lost and
people because i saw tassie tweet about
it um i went back to her and checked and
i don't have any more to get but i also
went through and got all of mine
recently so it could have been just a
later addition
yeah yeah i think i might have them all
done but yeah i i constantly forget to
do that that's such a big piece of the
game that they kind of hide from you
like you have to remember to go and like
talk to the stranger and it's just like
yeah i completely forgot to do that a
lot of seasons um yeah i'm probably
fully caught up though if season the
loss was the last one because i've been
remembering lately
um but yeah my i think um
before season of the hunt it was kind of
before
uh bungie's current like
streak of really good storytelling
started it was kind of like right on the
cusp there right we were starting sort
of starting to learn about the crow
but that that final cut scene and season
the hunt leaked and i remember that
everybody saw that video early um and so
there were there were they were sort of
like playing around with this
live action storytelling hadn't done
their first uh
their first like real-time event like
with the crash of um
whatever it was called the almighty oh
my god yeah almighty yeah hadn't done
that yet and so i think uh we were still
figuring out what
the future of destiny was going to look
like with the new seasonal model and
kind of that
very slow pace of drip storytelling that
now is sort of like very familiar to
people who play destiny but um
yeah i'm with gog i think it was kind of
the beginning of this year was a little
rough before we started getting a decent
seasons in
yeah i would agree i want to um first of
all definitely agree to agree that i
usually give titans a hard time
but i have to admit the stasis like
warlock's been balling on stasis like
stasis with us and the bleak turret and
everything like we definitely are the
beneficiary of stasis but titans by far
and hunters too like shadows has
literally shattered good lord yeah
shatter dive is its own thing the chase
the tornado that will shut down like
both of those but it's just like the
titans never
even the melee still feels bad to me to
this day
and it's just like one of those it's
like you can train yourself to like let
go early but i'm like why can't it work
like the other so i'm just running and
just like hit it to go connect it's like
just switching i've even heard other
people say that but
no i mean for me it was like yeah the
aramis campaign which is you know kind
of interesting with her lieutenants she
actually you got a little more empathy
for the fallen which i thought was
interesting yeah and that started some
of the storytelling a little bit more
than say like shadow keep which was
more
grand gesture with like the pyramid ship
and heiress and stuff and kind of
getting to know her ghost this was like
actually getting to know a different
race getting to know an enemy a little
bit more again the short-lived enemy
which we're kind of still accustomed to
which we're hoping doesn't happen in the
future which will be kind of covered
later
but the i think nice surprise with
beyond light for me was all the elsi and
anand
clovis a lot all like all that stuff for
me was really good somebody i think new
rad mentioned in chat like the lore
behind lament and baby 44.
so so good to see those um
lament as an exotic as well let's be
real that was that was really cool yeah
like intrinsic barrier sword kind of
doing unique animation right there
yep yeah so i was like
that stuff was cool then you had season
the hunt you had crippled hunts and you
were done with those after you literally
did one of them you're like oh
crap this is the scene like that's
i mean that's the thing and we'll get to
some of these as we talk about each of
like the activities we go through the
crow spider story as we said was like
i i understand you have to do certain
things but
move like do what you got to do and move
him because like the helm was introduced
till the next season which is where he
ended up but him just hanging out there
and i'm like put him anywhere i don't
care where put him anywhere else have
him in a different part another i don't
like that was kind of one of those
things but it's just like
really frustrating and then one of our
bigger debates
in that same season hawkmoon
oh yeah
but i remember your guys's debate you're
i think you're on this side it was
ivanta says it's not really hawkmoon
yeah yeah that was a fun one that was a
photo that was a funny way yeah i saw
you get roasted by that guest you had i
remember that
it's probably the best time i think it
was tony
it was
ill physics i don't know if he was the
one
oh oh no that was ascendant nomad yeah
nomad yes yes yes thank you for for
insisting that it wasn't he was like it
literally is but like okay
yeah
that was fun it was a fun debate i mean
look it came back
that i thought i thought i thought cloud
strike was really underrated i like
cloud i mean go ask cool guy he has had
more montage clips with that guy and
every soft on twitter he's just like yep
still love this night because i mean
just team wipe team just yeah massive
kills if you can time that thing
correctly and it's just if you're good
with a sniper
it is a beast in pvp if you can use and
i love the pve i love exotics
because usually there's a lot of crowd
control exotics you know which that's
all it's for but i love when there's
dual purpose like for example like an
outbreak perfected where it's like if
you do enough dps against the boss you
still get concentrated extra effort i
think thunder thunder um i mean what's
the the the exotic machine gun that
nobody
like they had a perk where they added
where again if you do continuous dps
against a boss
besides the ad clearing stuff you get
extra damage and i thought that i loved
that little smoke that cloud strike used
to do
that gives more dps towards bar so we
use that shot the back for daddy's in
there um that was a it was amazing it
was a mainstay for a little bit versus
tannics in deep stone like if you didn't
know the right loadouts that yeah if you
didn't have double event like is it
divinity
yeah if you didn't have divinity or if
you didn't have double precision
shoddies they were like yo if you got
klaus right you i you know kind of thing
so i i miss i like exotics like that and
i thought that and i hate generally i'm
not a sniper exotic guy that for
whatever reason that one i i was always
did well with i liked that one but we
got it we got to get them for salvation
script though
i was literally going to get there i was
like salvation's grip is literally just
a quest item that is all it is that's
all it is just to advance the story like
there's no function it is literally the
worst exotic like i i usually find any
use for that thing like i could use the
colony the prospector i could still use
those before i use salvation script
yeah that dashboard
yeah shout out oh dj orals in a building
salute what's going on but yeah like
they they need to do something with
salvation script trap like something i
mean i'm hoping it gets like one of
those like reworks or something because
now they're slowly introducing stasis
weapons and this season we're seeing
them more and we got a couple more with
like um is luna we're seeing a few more
come in with you know now you got cold
perks on the sword but yeah its
functionality needs to change it just
doesn't it doesn't do squat so no it's
it freezes people for 30 seconds in
crucible i think it'll start being part
of the meta
[Laughter]
that would be painful yeah that would be
painful but
it'll get a lot of uptick in usage
yeah we also got the harbinger mission
to get hawkmoon
so that was kind of then you had the
like people trying to break through the
walls of the little fireplace in the
cosmodrome and then figure that one out
and be like okay you start in the
cosmodrome you go through like two areas
and you're just staring at a damn you're
like where do i go that was my first
experience i'm like jump on this little
branch and go land on the edge of the
dam and you know how you kill the things
that final boss room to this day still
hurts if you are solo with a group it's
manageable but if you are solo and
depending on what week it's on
just the modifiers and the way the ads
are that thing is it's it was a
challenge solo i did it like once on
each week but man one of those weeks i
cannot remember what the
setup is sucks so bad yeah that's brutal
because it was so um
shield kind of game dependent and yeah
it's just so if you didn't have the
right setup you really you get tortured
in there i remember that it was a cool
quest you know we got we got more lore
on on your boy at the time you know
it was cool for what it was yeah like it
was cool to see it you had the feathers
a little bit with crow going back in his
little like apartment up in the rafters
up in there and stuff like that with
like the blanket and everything so it
was kind of cool uh it was also first
introduction to random world exotics
yes so again point forgot about that
coming back to our exotic of hawkmoon
was not really hawkmoon and now it's a
randomly rolled hawkmoon just just just
saying just here we go
anyway but it was not the right weapon
if it's randomly rolled
i mean it was the first one that ever
did that that's all yeah it's set to
trend set to trade right is there a
correct version of uh
what's this what's the scout rifle
dead man's tail yeah yeah i still don't
have uh four pole or four down
i'm actually kind of disappointed they
stopped doing um
bungee curated rolls i thought that was
cool
oh yeah you haven't seen that in a while
yeah i know what you mean not deep stone
[ __ ]
yeah it was almost like last week
yeah like last week you dropped the
curated master work time thing forgot
about that good point drive i forgot all
about those yeah
that was the thing yeah you be i
remember you get excited if you had that
that role in a raid
well speaking of dead man's tale the
next season that came across was season
of the chosen and this is where
the title story and zavala basically
just talking straight up to uh
to the you know empress per se uh so
that was an entertaining meme moment
along with some great memes from lance
riddick those were hilarious
battlegrounds were introduced and
progressed as we went through the season
got a few of them unlocked as we went
the helm was introduced along with the
umbrellas and the war table which really
allowed them to tell stories in a
different way i think it opened up their
abilities to put multiple characters and
places come through in projections and
it really started to get them on this
path of telling stories in the season on
a weekly basis which
will kind of save my the idea of how the
stories are told i have a couple things
to kind of touch on in the end uh the
proving ground strike we actually did
get our new first new strike in a while
oh yeah also bringing back devil's lair
and fallen saber so we got one new
strike plus two old ones for a mix
uh tku's divination that was your
seasonal exotic
um again if you got to bring a exotic
bowen was it fun and it ended up being
actually pretty solid and then pressage
nobody uses it though
pressage was
just ultra unique i mean that was like
aliens in like the aliens movie
just put into destiny in
such a cool way the environments the
sounds a little bit of puzzling to it
the way the fight was set up overall
very very cool mission um lots of fun to
do if you haven't done it yet please
make sure you do that before it leaves
in february uh but yeah we're for season
of the chosen
that's the first one that really got a
little chance to stand on its own after
stasis and everything is settled we get
title we get battlegrounds where did
what did this start doing for you guys
to move this year forward travis
oh yeah i think that's where it really
started kicking off for me because uh i
think that was the first seasonal event
where i felt like the um
the match made activity was actually
good
you know like i i've really not liked
any of the matchmaking activities
including menagerie really i mean it was
good a few times but it gets boring
pretty quick but battlegrounds or the uh
the battlegrounds was awesome because
the enemy density was unlike anything
we'd ever seen before and there's just
so many enemies coming at you and
there's just like lots of combat and
cool stuff yeah you can't play them
forever but they were at least like
they were a lot more tolerable to grind
than i think any of the other seasonal
activities before then and they weren't
a public event thank god uh so
uh yeah i i really liked that um that
that activity and think uh the story had
everybody talking like every week people
were like are we really gonna lie with
kaido like what the heck is going on and
there's that epic moment with the crow
and zavala at the end and i have a lot
of really good memories story wise of
that season and of just doing the combat
and thank god we got a new strike that
was our
first new strike since forsaken
no what about shadow keep we got one we
got the harp
forgot about that
the scarlet keep yeah but that was like
literally one brown strike since
forsaken in that long
because i mean we didn't get a strike
with beyond light did like did we yeah
it was the running show oh no we got one
we got the what is the one with the two
oh yeah
with homegirl
yeah we got one there as well but again
it'd been like we're going like
expansions in one strike like
yeah seemed pretty smart so to get one
in like the next season was actually a
big surprise plus two extras from d1
which
new to some but you know old hat to
others
fallen sabers fond table not a main
expansion either which i don't think
we'd ever really seen uh side ones where
we were getting a lot of new strikes
except for i think they did that in d1
but yeah that was huge
um yeah i have really fond memories i
think that's one of my favorite seasons
looking back at it um
that wasn't the season with the almighty
was it no it wasn't no almighty was that
was season the worthy right
i think so yeah it's been right before
the hunt right
arrivals was after worthy right before
beyond light came out yeah
yeah pretty close
you know yeah um
yeah i i really like that season i have
no complaints also i remember there
being a lot of good weapons to farm
mm-hmm yeah the chosen weapons you have
the smg frenzy was introduced that's
right debuted frenzy debut yep
yeah the smg was was was crazy um
code dwello rocket launchers really got
the rise the rocket launcher rolls in
that one they keep getting rises it's
still not there
i don't know i don't know
we got that yeah i'm waiting which i
have man that season is chosen super
strong for me um
everything trav said the the reason why
i liked it was because it was the first
time
enemy density was so much that you had
to watch front and back
and you were like yo what is going on
and remember that stupid sound
it's not like a bird call every time
you're there you're like oh when you
when you're in there you walk a ball
drop down and walk a ball and drop down
like what is going on it was crazy um i
love that one tiku's definition is one
of my favorite exotics they've ever done
i don't like boats i'll be hon
i didn't learn about how efficient bows
were until i actually the game
forced me to do it for the catalyst or
whatever and i'm like yo this is really
good like then it was almost like a um
what's that thing like uh
you light someone on fire and then you
you know you you stepped up and then you
prime them and you blow them up
basically
probably blow them up and it was just
like it was such a cool mechanic and i
remember loving that the reason why
season of the chosen
hits hard for me was they really dug
deep on narrative voice acting i
remember doing strikes and hearing
saladin and him complain and you know
you would get characters you would never
my major beef with destiny was npcs
would not interact prior to that yeah
there'd be all this stuff going on in
the world and no one's really talking
with each other outside whoever the main
story was focused on but with
battlegrounds you get hoth i mean um
amanda at a chime in a mission or two
you get you know the crow to chime in
you get crow to kind of check saladin on
funny things or cyrus would come in and
he would talk and so you get these
differing perspectives and i love that
cause i'm like okay this window like
this one you know say kind of thing and
i thought narratively they really
started to take off cattle was she was a
good introduction we we that's what i
think we're going to say e we kind of
started the whole
potential allies
of former enemies absolutely that kind
of thing kicked off we got the two
strikes how we finally got a damn strike
whatever the helm
i thought the helmet was solid you know
it really i think the helm was the debut
of how they're going to kick off really
better storytelling yeah you know saying
it's what once the helm debuted and it
was like almost like it was like an
avengers
you know thing you come to the board
this is the avengers 4 table what's
going on this week and yeah prestage i i
think you like that was amazing that was
wow they they really
it was horror you know at the time we
didn't know he was so suspicious we
still thought it was osiris but we saw
the whole
you know cato's interaction
and yeah great i thought it was a solid
season i mean my only complaint if i had
to nitpick would just be you know the
typical bungee gap between
when you're gonna finally get the moment
with zavala and crow and the ambush
remember what you call the ambush each
other
ambush
yeah that's my only beef with it because
you know the typical like all right come
on come on we want to know we want to
know we want to know and it's like wait
the e the major e complaint that i know
he's on goldie yeah we'll get to that at
the end but yes absolutely e i rambled
what about you like was was caesar the
chosen as high as it was for both of us
for being sure oh i mean yeah it really
turned the ship with regards to them
telling a story in the game
uh whether you like the weekly bit or
not some people like to binge some
people like the weekly episodes it got
to a point where we did have just enough
to discuss now it could still be just
the tuesday login but it was actually
synced enough and you could catch up
later maybe i think they pop the catch
up later i don't know if it was that
season or the next but either way they
made it to where you could
like experience that story even if
you're like hey i can only play like one
day a week you could still be part of
that story and that experience that
kaidel and zavala and all of that stuff
going on seeing the zavala and crow
moment for half a second which was cool
like that
redemption arc a little bit there with
what he did to help save zavala um and
then as you said like you guys have said
most of it we actually got new strikes
multiple we were in desperate need for
some of those
um
and between the battlegrounds and the
helm i mean you kind of mentioned
something i kind of forgotten it was the
helm helped with the war table tell the
story with the holograms and like you
know people walking in and standing
there listening everything but the voice
over you got made the battlegrounds feel
after a while you may have heard them
all but there was enough between
different weeks and seeing different
things and the progression and who's
talking to who crows checking salad and
salad and talking into osir like so many
different pieces on the board and you
actually it made the world feel more
alive overall yes yes
and that was really nice because we've
had all these npcs and they mostly just
sit on the side while we go do our
god-killing thing as guardians and it
hasn't been a whole lot else and now it
feels like a
more robust world with npcs that we
actually talk to
yeah i mean that was about major beef
prior to that yeah that's those were big
and then for me it's like the the
missions are special uh pressage for
example they're always going to be cool
for me like harbinger was but pressage
pressage was
something on another level um just the
tone that it sets
uh the different steps that you had to
go through
and just overall i mean you had the star
wars moment in there you had the trash
compactor moment oh yeah shoved into a
quest when it felt like aliens and like
the sound if you're playing with
headphones it feels like the things like
everywhere around you you start in the
outside you don't even know how to know
how to get into this thing your ship's
just like just the scale of what it did
to put you in the middle of space on
this alien ship and now you got to go
inside and figure out what the hell
happened and then you get the scout
rifle that breaks the game for about six
months until they finally nerf it down
because
it's a scout rifle that fires like last
word and people like i don't need the
last word i have a scout rifle that does
it even better
text mechanic and weapons be looking
sleek too yeah i'm text mechanical
joints
clean
so yeah i mean overall i would say my
biggest thing which is something they're
learning a little but it's still
and we'll kind of touch on this a little
bit it's the upgrading of the seasonal
interaction device the servitor
upgrading the water table upgrading the
hell the gauntlet that painful like
here's this thing and it got that almost
got worse as we will talk about that but
it was just the war table of you know
your progression of just as you went
through certain unlocks yeah and they
gave more functionality to it in splicer
which we'll get to but in seasonal loss
they almost took a step back for me on
some of that so i want i want to give
them a little credit
they even though it wasn't done
all the way well
they tried to play with tier three focus
embryo engrams with the with the either
the extra perk in the tier the tier
three thing
and some slight target farming where
it'd be like you could get either the
rocket or this would it would have
started that with the umbrellas that's
true but the costs were like very high
it was like ridiculous high to do it
kind of thing but at least they
attempted i believe in caesar that had
chosen
yeah because that's where umbrals were
introduced so it's like it's the work
the umbrals the prismatic decoder or
recaster all that stuff kind of came
around and then i think the focus is
started there so we got to see
unlocking a little bit more targeting
levels of targeting and that type of
stuff i think that did start there so
was it it was the first step and then
it's kind of we've had some progression
from there into
the next piece is season of the splicer
so season of the supply store season of
the grenade launcher depending on what
you had in your inventory and uh mods
equipped we had the endless knight kind
of take over the tower so we have this
whole vex problem going on then we pair
up now this time another ally we have
the fallen
and they're the house of what were they
the house of light what is their house
yeah
okay
uh and you have the mythrax saint 14
story which we'll break into that here
in a second i'll let you have that one
cog uh the helm we had the server
sitting in the helm we had fallen in the
city we had fallen in their own little
part of scourge of the past
um
activities wise we got override and
expunged we had the three normal then
the three corrupted then the finale
armor synthesis was introduced
which
right nearly broke our our friend here
travis that's that's his greatest rant
of all time
this goat rate and then uh cog nearly
lost his mind vault of glass came back a
couple weeks after the season started
vex mythic last game
uh
so
so good season of the splicer man where
where are you at i don't know what it is
clearly biased with season in this
flight like let me just disclaimer
myself this is the season for me like
this was
vault came back so automatically i'm
already this already gets a curve for
[ __ ] right i i get that i wanted to see
how they how they would do it
um very pleased with vac smith the class
i was very pleased because that was one
of my major well didn't it start kind of
stinky
right you're right it did start yeah
they had to buff it no you're right
you're right take it back it didn't
debut well they they oh they nerfed it
and then they but when they did buff it
in the same season though i think it was
a quick turnaround right i'm gonna say
it was a quick turn i don't remember
waiting that long for that buff i feel
like it was long i feel like it was
long enough
was it in the same season that it got
buffed though
maybe i'm wrong i think it got better
more recently
or like season to loss maybe guy drive
no we got d it got debuffed in season
lost the vex smith i can't remember yeah
i just remember
it because i got it the first week and i
just remember it being absolutely sloppy
and right in the beginning trials and
crucible yeah it was just disgusting so
what did it get perfect how about you
research when it got buffed when did the
buff actually happen somebody in the
chat will probably know
well like recently uh the aim assist got
taken down for people
but anyway back on track with actual the
season
um yeah it was it was it was good
storytelling mythrax i'll be honest
i didn't at first like mythrax the way i
like kyle i'll be i was like okay
we'll see what you're about
okay i was all about saint 14's
portrayal
like the way
he was portrayed because we think it was
this lovable guy and everyone he's
everyone's favorite he's probably
welcome one of my favorite titans
besides um what you call it all shacks
and to see the monster thing yep to see
mithrax tell the story oh you think that
you know you're the hero like you are
feared here you've killed children
you've murdered like you are a threat to
every fallen who sees you that's not how
you're perceived bro and it was kind of
like he had to go walk off saying
remember walked off and checked himself
like yo like that's crazy how my actions
are perceived again um we got that now
the reason why this season was for me
is because this was when
laxmi was making the town great again
she was uh
she was a fallen racist propaganda you
know what i'm saying like she she was
you know i loved the actress who played
her she's like you know you can't trust
them then she planted the seeds she had
beef with akora but she was just like
look you know they do with the vagabond
doing things behind our back and then
like
calls her out type
now override wasn't that great i ain't
gonna lie or i wasn't that great but
trav the best override mission was the
last one when we started it and you see
laxmi on the ground everybody was like
teabagging and taking pictures of
actually dead
and then let's be out of the grand
finale
oh suspicious reveals himself because i
mean it not reveals himself totally but
looks over yeah and that's the first
time everybody's like nah fam that ain't
right you that ain't right something's
going on with this dude because he's
looking over the battlefield and then
angrily walks away and then everyone's
like yo say it's like yo make it right
just tell everybody what happened why
did you disappear you know what's going
on and that's when we really started to
see this plant the seeds of him being
evil um
last thing i'll say i did like
i probably i don't know if me and you
talk about this
i did like expunge missions
i don't know what it was about them uh
whether it's the techie the tron i liked
that savithoon or whoever was talking to
us in cold it added a nice little
eeriness to the mission i like that they
rewarded you for completing the expunge
missions in very quick times the weapons
were good ignition code the auto rifle
chrome whatever
chromochromerus um
yeah the pulse rifle was good um
yeah the the target farming i i really
like seasonal splice it has some couple
of little negatives here and there
but i overall liked it and to travis's
point yeah vex did start off oh yeah
christina was kind of trash at first
when it first dropped it first got
better
yeah
yeah but that's that's what i got i mean
would you what did you where do you
stand with caesar displacement
yeah season the spicer is definitely my
least favorite of like the most recent
ones um
both because of armor synthesis and all
the just
but also i think they started vaulting
that season i think maybe that was
season of the hunt but there was like a
lot of vaulting they did around that
time um the cosmodrome i remember got
added and we were like
we thought maybe they'd use it more in
later seasons after see after uh
was it chosen chosen because
no what was it beyond light started
cosmodrome was there as like just the
intermission and they fleshed out
cosmodrome when they added the strikes i
think that's how that works so it was it
was full before slicer forgot about that
so there was that i do i don't like
expunge or the the the um six player
matchmaking advantage thought it was
super
repetitive and i didn't want to spend a
lot of time of it the art the upgrading
of your your artifact
or the activity you had to upgrade the
the path with the activity that i
thought was super grindy um
i also don't really
care about the story that much like i
get why we had to lie with the fallen
but mythrax was kind of out of nowhere
in my opinion like
it's not like they were a leader it was
just kind of a random group of fallen
and it's a guy that we killed before in
destiny
let him
pending right you can kill i think i
killed people that's right yeah you
killed him um anyway
uh yeah
um
and then
yeah it was just sort of like um
vaulted glass coming back i love all the
glass but i really am not a fan of like
people using the old stuff that used to
be good and remastering and giving it
back to us and all that stuff i'm glad i
got uh um vex smith the class thank you
so much because i had just gotten done
getting destroyed by eyes of tomorrow
and uh in the deep stone crypt so i was
happy for that but um yeah the the the
storyline was a little sloppy for me i
really liked the lakshmi plot but i feel
like it ended really poorly just like
her dying off screen and then uh you
know hideo and
um
oh that was wacky yeah
and leaving yeah leaving nowhere just to
kill faction rally
yeah yeah there's the explanation there
we've got to get rid of all of our
factions yeah that was whack and then
also the villain was basically no one
like remember that final boss fight was
like the big vex that obviously was
was part of the woman yeah yeah yeah
cory and war mined which was obviously
part of um
part of the witch queen's plan
savithun's plan but uh it it i felt like
we were chasing a phantom the whole time
and the answer was super underwhelming
it's like oh it was this random vex
person but definitely like the witch
queen is behind it and it's like okay
cool but like when are we gonna get to
that part um see i i definitely um i
remember playing a lot less than i
normally do that season um and and not
not big sur rubber also people were all
about the small one and i hate i hate
why you hate the smaller baby anything
do you hate do you oh puppies puppies
you like puppies do you like kittens i
do hate puppies i don't like people i
like animals
i don't like animals and i especially
don't like to put some warmness in your
heart
you got too much coldness in your heart
yeah i don't know about too much i think
it's the right amount i think it keeps
me it keeps me insane but yeah
um
uh yeah so yeah there's that that too
just really nothing for me in the season
i guess is my point really nothing for
me at all it's a different target
audience
fair enough i love that
hey fandom
not all seasons for everybody also i i
need i need to say this one more time
before we end
this segment
yes our synthesis
yeah
sure
yeah yeah i'm curious about your
assessment of uh no i mean i would say i
would lean closer to you on splicer for
sure um endless night getting myth rex
is cool like th this is where they're
leaning more into like the animated
storyboards as you said like saint as a
monster that was
that was top tier like i mean
seeing the way that was portrayed seeing
just that perspective shift and watching
somebody like saint who
trials commentary and all that stuff and
then all of a sudden you see him just
hanging his head after he's told of how
he's portrayed he was really really cool
seeing like i cora just want to light up
latch me it was a little cat fight and
that's why i was like that's they're
leaning more and more into these like
voice over pieces and like those
interactions that like just the intercom
or the voice mails that we had
those were some of the best pieces
depending on who it like watch me is
just like trying to spread her
propaganda and all this stuff and then
ikora comes in you stop that right like
she just wanted to just shut her down
and would like nova bomb her if she
politically could without being like
just taking everybody off so i was like
i enjoyed those pieces of it i think as
travis said
like quaria who is this like you know
taken vex mind crazy crazy and i was
like as you for like override fine like
you do so many you were just like
pulling your hands like yeah any of that
stuff like fine
but if sponge i'm with you i did enjoy
because you had the normal ones first
and then you had the corrupted versions
which had a little bit of a shift to
them and then you had the finale which
was kind of a cool combination of all
three um i just enjoyed those as like
they're little single player run-offs
for me so anything that's so low for me
i'm going to enjoy probably a little bit
more be proud i did those all solo
myself i really really go so we go
really do anything so i'll continue yeah
uh yeah cryostasia was garbage um when
it came out and vex was a little bit
doo-doo
uh but that did get corrected later uh
vault came out and was loved by a lot of
people we had the normal the and then
you had the hard mode version
and we didn't even mention fate bringing
y'all fate bringer came back
it's an old gun
and that's kind of one of those where
it's like it could be that [ __ ]
it's an old gun
i feel like people need to stop uh
praising bungie for bringing back old
[ __ ] just i mean i agree
you just you decided to abandon it with
destiny one like don't don't expect a
praise from us just because you changed
your mind i i agree
i'm with tassie on this taxi made a good
point i think
with you all right for saying
we shouldn't give them over praise them
for bringing back old stuff but i do
agree with tasks in a sense that i don't
think we give them enough credit like i
think what's happened is the narrative
has not flipped like that season or
these seasons when they bring back old
stuff that that's all they did right but
the reality is if you look at everything
they've brought out way more new stuff
and new web a whole new line of weapons
even the season of the spicer weapons
the new exotics we talked about the um
the expunge mission and that i mean on
crystal and dead man's tail there's way
more new weapons that they've added and
the old stuff is a supplement and i
think sometimes we get caught and roll
our eyes because we see old stuff and
think that's the majority of what they
did that's what i want to say but i'm
sorry again and that honestly like takes
me back to
um
one thing that people are probably
screaming if you're listening to this
later on you're like are you ever gonna
say it sun setting
smooth forgot that with beyond the light
and then the step back with chosen
when did it become blight is when sunset
season 8 and backwards gone
yeah that was and then
it was season
of the chosen when that started there
like anything that's playable here will
be playable from here forward
so it's like season eight and nine
season eight backwards and then you lost
season nine so it was like ten forward
you got to keep and that was
and again that's the thing is exactly
what you were saying it kind of makes
sense vault yeah vault's still full
always full um
but that makes sense as you said they
keep
if they would have started now with like
bringing back vault bringing back more
weapons and then reissuing some other
ones
the reissue is somehow like where
they're like kind of cheating as travis
is saying they're cheating to be like
hey here's new weapons that you had two
years ago
with some different perks and it's like
they're kind of playing the back and
forth on that stuff so it's like but sun
setting was this massive decision which
got reverted three months later and
pretty much i feel like they just wanted
to get rid of recluse and mountaintop
and
you know basically just the pinnacle
weapons
and unfortunately
we paid a lot for it and then now
they're slowly trying to build back up
our arsenal weapons there's not a solar
bow that's legendary
yeah unless you have the one from last
wish which i do but i'm sitting there
going through a guide i'm like oh you
want a solar bow
okay you have tikkus that is it unless
you go do the last tuition you get lucky
for a drop and how many people go run
last wish like that's the type of thing
if you have an archetype and a slot and
you're and you're going to tell me you
have to use bows for overload
you don't have a lot of options like you
need to start filling these things out
and that that's where the sun setting
it backfired because it took away so
much they took away so much that we
ended up losing archetypes that were
necessary to pair with the artifact when
it come to whether it be anti-barrier
overload because there just wasn't
enough in a certain category like it
just we it really bad they didn't
produce enough to even justify
sunsetting in theory it would have been
nice but yeah the execution was horrible
i completely agree with you guys there
um but yeah i mean it's like vault was
cool it was cool to go back but i mean
that was the one raid i've played the
most outside of probably kings fall um
so going back in there was like it had a
few twists but it was like it felt like
vault so it was nice to have it back for
the people who hadn't played it
but it was like for me it was not fresh
it was like it was cool to go back in
and play in destiny 2 and it's cool to
see on pc i mean when i got into my new
monitor it looks gorgeous in there but
it's like the mechanics were it was
still vault which is what they wanted to
do that with just a few twists with like
here's a couple champions i got to take
care of the wyvern we're a little bit
new in a few places but overall mostly
the same um
i don't know it's like after you get the
cool moment like deep stone [ __ ] space
walk vault of glass was never going to
come
to that level of like a cool moment
because we'd already we'd had those cool
moments they were just years before
um but yeah i mean the loot was good we
got time lost weapons so we got kind of
our first adept
um like adept pve stuff i think that's
where those started i don't know if that
started with i don't know which season
the gm started to do at depths i'd have
to go back and look but those were more
outside of gm's i guess is where you
started to get those time-lost adept
weapons who could take those mods um
overall i mean as a store as a package
with override did wear itself out and
i'm with travis those grinds on those
things
i mean the grinds on astral is probably
the worst because it just smacks you in
the face with the like this come back
next week like it literally says it on
screen and i feel like that hurt me more
we'll get to that override was still
just so grindy and it's like you have to
go into there to get the currency for
you could afk and override
oh yeah you have a low key yeah 100
incomplete
sorry you could do no yeah i mean that's
kind of the thing you had
those the upgrade paths are
so
time gated heavy in this moment and then
in start of lost that's one of those
things when we get to like hopes for the
future
that's kind of one of those that i hope
they learn and again it's that six
months cadence that i do hope that's
some of the changes that we start to see
it's like they were just mid sequence on
that one but overall i mean the story
was cool saint 14 lakshmi
corey it was a bit of a letdown
unfortunately but the helm we still had
talking to and again you had those
interactions with you and mythrax and
saint talking over here
and then you know icora won't just light
up there were there were very cool
moments expunges were fun thought was
vault was you know a cool addition to
get just any raid that close so overall
i would say for like that like
expansion
cool season
big season splicer i think lived up to
it pretty well
um i did want to backtrack
both of y'all on um
each season i wanted to recall what was
the
like for example like right now we have
particle deconstruction as the
default meta thing
breaching one clear supply clearance all
right launchers so that was splicing
richard clay with spicer what was chosen
i don't know see i was trying to think
back to i don't remember what was like
the major
yeah
yeah i don't remember i feel like it was
more things like
do damage with void before they started
leaning heavy into the
i feel like that's what it was and then
like grenade launchers all of a sudden
became like
right but salvaged any grenade launcher
all the way became amazing because
bridges was slicer
right
so what i remember would be
if i if unless i'm forgetting another
thing that was similar to breech and
clear i remember breaching clear that
was my first time like yo what is this
oppressive darkness well that's the one
i was thinking of yeah oppressive
daughters right and but that present dog
was kind of like a it was around for a
while for my my understanding right it's
come and go i think we've had it twice
it's like it's come and gone anyway yeah
but it's two different seasons
the point is breaching clear to me
represented the first time bungie tried
to influence a meta oh and hardcore
grenade launchers were like you had to
use this if you're going to place atheon
you had to use this and that was the
first time you'd get the visual the boss
would glow saying that you've triggered
and initiated this thing and now we
could do crazy damage and
i don't know how i feel all the way
about it some matters i did like it but
i feel this is them debuting and really
influencing yo you got to have this you
got to have this thing kind of thing and
we'll go on with the next i just wanted
to mention that because i remember that
was a big thing i think i didn't even
know what preacher clinton everybody at
the time was like yo we got to have that
we doing we need we need you to get this
for anything i had to redo my artifact
just to get to because i had
underestimated i didn't know what it was
kind of thing and that leans into where
we are now at least season wise in
season of the lost uh so we got marasov
crowe
and sabathune at least in crystal form
all of that story going on a weekly
basis crow trying to figure out what
happened in his past uh basically coming
face to face with petra marasov
obviously us going through all of those
pieces uh we had astral alignment that
was your sixth player with a couple
different varieties for a match made
kind of making use of the blind well so
you can see them building some spaces
but also using already you know
previously used in-game assets for boss
fights
but we did have shattered realm which i
think a lot of us thoroughly enjoyed
multiple at facets of what that had to
offer the changes over a weekly basis to
metroidvania style pieces
crossplay actually became big in this
season um
cross play between all consoles
basically being a giant platform pve was
next to everybody pvp is consoles and
then pc are pretty much your only two
separations that was a big big addition
uh also with that this season we've had
trials labs multiple pieces we've had
solo trials with a freelance playlist
we've had trials capture point they've
actually experimented and this is
probably the first time we've had the
most discussion over crucible in a jesus
christ
long long time
but we've had i mean we got we got a
dissertation on crucible
so we got to get some idea what's coming
and then we also got aggroceptor
so
that was a big thing for stasis and also
we got the lawrence driver and that kind
of pairs into his weapons
yep stasis weapons actually with uh
these
mostly unfortunate we learned that those
are right now at least mostly stasis
agriceptor is different as an exotic uh
legendary species weapons legendary
stasis weapons get a little bit of a
tease with the headstone perk but
overall not like
weapons that do freezing damage in
general unless we're talking about
something like agriceptor
but it was the season i mean this right
now is the season of the fusion
whether it be linear or not this is the
scene because particle deconstruction so
again we had one of those perks that
truly took the meta and was like this is
what you should probably play with if
you've got any type of them it is
advantageous to do so
um
so who took the last one travis
was so trapped
travis is up mm-hmm
i think he's in the blast
yeah i think i've seen before but my i
think seasonal loss is one of the better
better seasons um obviously it went on
it's gone on like way longer than any of
us would have liked because of the delay
and um the 30th anniversary has sort of
revitalized that which i think we'll
probably talk about separately but um
season the lost is really strong because
we finally got introduced to our enemy
in in person we got a reveal right off
the bat uh i still don't like any match
made activities for you know the seasons
that i have to do a million times um
but i uh i do like um
i do like uh
what
what we the shattered realms the shadow
realms was like by far one of my
favorite
activities and doing that alone and just
sort of like exploring the area and
finding all that stuff has been super
cool um and then obviously there was the
abrupt stop which i'm not a fan of uh
yeah and then the waiting and then us
not really hearing from sabbath or
having any sort of i feel like kind of
they've lost the momentum right there's
so much momentum and like fear around
sabbath that now by february we're going
to have forgotten was even a thing and i
think that's unfortunate hopefully
they'll do something to kick start that
again but it almost feels like the
events that happened with sabathan
should have happened
all together
the beginning of february we should have
gotten it at the beginning that's gonna
be one of my overarching discussions
we'll get there
stop that you know right yeah
anyway travis continue
yeah but yeah i uh
i actually don't mind the rollout i
think i'll probably be on the opposite
side of that debate uh just because i
like
uh ibonta says uh we should get it all
at once i don't know if i agree no i'm
not saying i'm not because i'm selfish
okay not all at once
no all i've said is like i want if
episode seven is
week seven
episode eight is the season finale
shouldn't be week 37
it should be week eight that's all i'm
saying oh yeah i agree with that i agree
i feel that that's a different argument
i thought you were going to say we
should get like the whole story
the weekly the drip has the drip has
actually grown on me
the way they've actually done it
no it's like i've said this slowly
throughout the years that the drip has
slowly
grown but again the ending kills me of
each of these seasons
yeah we already knew we got the trailer
for which queen why do you feel like you
have to wait for this reveal of the
chrysalis
to should have been on week nine
whenever the season was done and then
you're gonna have some time it's like
they're not getting any benefit with the
delay as travis said the momentum is out
of the train yeah so when it finally
comes back it's just gonna be weird
anyway oh yeah sorry travis i think i
still here
yeah i know i'm glad you you said that
you clarified your opinion because i'm
uh i think one of the things that's been
great about destiny this year is because
we haven't had any major expansions i
haven't felt like i've had to rush to
play things i'm able to play log on for
the you know the week when it comes out
play a little bit of the story but never
feel like i just hate destiny and don't
want to have to play it anymore which i
felt before in the past when they give
us you know so much content we have to
log on every day for like two months to
get through it and there's like a lot of
pressure to stay relevant and like stay
up with the meta and keep your power
higher um but i think uh
you're right like the the way that the
the timing is the worst part like they
just do these seasons and then you have
to wait forever to get to the ending and
i i honestly think they're gonna need to
recap by the time we finish the sabbath
yeah
i really don't remember it
i don't remember what happened on the on
the eighth or ninth week or whatever the
hell it was to to get to the end there
so
i feel like they they do need to recap
um
yeah and also right now we're all doing
like 30th anniversary stuff which feels
so so frivolous and detached and then
the halloween event and the christmas
event and now it's just like our
guardians are having fun and like
i'm so detached from like the doom that
was hanging over us during the day
it's just kind of ridiculous it's like
now i've been baking cookies for the
past like what do you want like i'm not
i'm not thinking about savage food what
do you want to have doing a baking cream
yeah dude i i honestly am surprised
because they didn't have it
yeah i'm surprised they didn't have us
bring savathun's crystal some cookies
very surprised
i honestly figured that was gonna be one
of the new recipes and it's just like
every week if they would have made the
pile of cookies in her chamber bigger
and bigger
oh
yeah they had us do it to the dragon in
the last wish range yeah yeah we had to
give it to rivers
i told i totally could have seen them
giving cookies to the crystal sabathon
and i was just being like okay whatever
i'm glad they didn't do that i could i
could also see them bringing like
bringing us bringing cookies to osiris's
corpse or wherever the heck is hanging
out at this point i that that's how like
that's the cognitive dissonance i feel
between the story and what i've been
doing in destiny i've been hanging out
with like us an astral pony and just
making jokes and i feel like it doesn't
fit at all the tone i was feeling so
yeah i like season the lost a lot i
think it's definitely a step up from the
previous season splicer um but yeah the
the timing and how long it's going on i
think has really been brutal um and i
think uh they're gonna have to do a lot
of work to prep for february i feel
they've lost a lot of momentum so that's
how i feel i i i like it though i i
still need to grind all those damn dares
of eternity man like that's yeah i'm
really not looking forward to that
that's such a such an uphill climb but
uh yeah i'm gonna do it for that damn
catalyst because
yeah
yeah i've been you know um
yeah trav pretty much said everything i
want to say
i'll just add more soft it was cool to
come back just to see you know it's been
a while we haven't seen her we wanted to
know how she played in this whole grand
scheme of the schemer the season of the
schemer no
i'm calling it season loss you know
savage doing was more chilling than ever
i thought i loved it always gave me a
little uneasiness every week where it's
like you do your mission
your friend so you gotta go talk to her
yeah and it made me uncomfortable being
in that chamber with her i did not like
it so that was great storytelling um
crow finally you know the the reveal
with outside the betrayal you know a lot
of in-depth with him you know
him being confused that whole bit
astral alignment i always gonna love
dreamwing city and i thought the
activities were fine i just think it
goes on too long like actual lavender
just a long activity and that's my only
thing i didn't mind each other thing but
i just wish maybe one or two a cut and
it'd just be a little shorter i didn't
you know that kind of thing um i'm with
trap shattered realm was fire like that
was like
some old metro vania type situation it
was it was just cool you know unlocking
things destiny really never did anything
like that where i was like okay this is
unique this is cool this is fun we got
to cross play that was great um
i'm a huge fan of aegis after
that that's like stuck to me right now
it's a it's a whole build for me i love
the dual functionality when your super
is um at max and you can use it as a
very powerful weapon
it pay for warlocks we're eating with
that lavatory right with that that
exotic that when we have your super
and you do more damage with age receptor
and then also like when you use the
power and you drain your super and you
can build your super back up to get the
age it's it's a great synergy lorentz
driver i slept on i was getting killed a
lot by it in pvp and i got mad i was
like why am i getting one shot at by
this thing
well there is driving yeah your
teammates getting killed by it because
they get pulled into you that's the
approval of it yeah celebrate guilt such
guilt flows over me when in trials my
team dies because i got headshot oh yes
yo
beast we got the crossplay finally that
was huge you know me he got to see each
other we ran up on each other when he
first debuted i was like all right
where's he at it works yes and it works
in all my pc friends that was huge
but you know travis again said it best
they have all this great stuff there's
momentum it's it's seeming fun and it's
just stop
dead stop and it's just like
i stopped caring it was just too long
again it was like normally we get
through there was one seat was it a
rivals that had a long what this has to
be like it feels like the longest gap
between the conclusion of it
because the season got delayed i mean
it's by far because probably it's like
seven or eight weeks and then final week
or two of the season but it's normally a
12-week season not a 24-week season or
however long it ends up being and that's
a shame go ahead the last one i'll just
say it was just a shame because it was
such a good season the last thing is i
am a fan of particle deconstruction i
you know i'm team fusion i love linears
i love regular
i liked seeing this thing run crazy and
sleeper and everybody dusting off their
little fusion rifles and you know and
what's the oh we got for trials we got
on i like that stasis one
i like reeds i like reeds a lot triple
tap firing line
you know kind of thing and yes you know
the running joke was we would see you
know the last word was the last word on
trials every week because it is damn
because caesar didn't have anything
going on all we had to talk about was
trials every week there was nothing else
going on
i feel like they talked more about and
did more work on trials in season of the
loss than they did in season of the
worthy
yes the season that was about trial so i
feel like you didn't get as much
i 100 agree so much trial still it was
so much true because that it literally
showed you they had nothing else going
on really but that
sadly also shows how little had been
done on crucible before
because i mean it was like a complete fl
180 the other direction because it was
like 600 days since the crucible map or
the promise to make crucible great again
and then you see how much they talk
about it in depth in every 12 every week
and you're like
there's no middle ground here like just
absolute dead zone or overabundance and
there's no middle ground for crucible
discussion so
it's interesting let me get a new rare
right quick he said cog
it's just six months it's still not long
as d1 i love the gap back then and i
could do what i wanted and leave i hear
you on the gaps on as far as losing
coming back those are completed stories
but those are thank you yeah chad just
took my point about it you can't leave
to like ibontes and travis point a story
unfinished for six months didn't expect
to have major anticipation coming back
like i have literally stopped caring
about
savvithun resolution because i have
forgotten it's been so long now to we're
gonna get into 30th anniversary right
after e but it's like we're doing this
and i'm baking cookies and i'm doing
this and i'm doing joke stuff with other
you know we get into the other
activities i forgot what we're supposed
to be doing which is
waiting for this great betrayal to to
marisol and the guardian that kind of
thing so that that's what i was going to
say i mean i don't have a problem with
gaps i just have a problem with gaps
that are unfinished but there's no
conclusion to a narrative but e your
thoughts seasonal loss this whole day uh
yeah i mean starting off with like
marisov crowe petra
uh i mean one of the best ones was mara
and aikora went at each other on the
voicemail i mean they were back they
were literally about to just take each
other's heads off both of them on you
know she's on her weird astral plane or
whatever she's doing i-core just wants
to again just go full warlock on her and
i've never seen i mean those two people
you do not want to piss either of them
off and they're mad at each other like
enough to want to just kill each other
so
just the level of emotions that some of
the acting brings out in this season got
deep crow is like
so torn as to why he can't get answers
that he wants to be given nobody wants
to tell him petra's keeping him out
basically lock and key he then sneaks in
talks to savithoon there's the dogs
barking um
it's fine i took one of my neighbors a
slice of cheesecake and they returned to
the plate so yeah i could barely hear
them though you're good yeah um so i
mean that was the thing but again like
as you guys said shattered realm for me
was a blast also you know the higher
difficulty will just kick your butt
trying to do one of the you got to do
them solo or whatever it
man each one of those weeks every every
week hit a different piece the piece
that just wanted to ruin you but the the
the scorned one with the bouncing ark
balls it's the
uh debris of dreams oh my god
that middle that middle
one that you've got to like
that one sucked but then on the other
side astral alignment as you said it had
some variety had the dreaming city theme
which is pretty to look at but it is
that six player match made activity and
then once you've done three you've kind
of done them all get them all and then
they want you to do it 50 times and
anybody i forgot that was in the game to
be honest
right now it's been so long and then
it's going to go away and that's kind of
the weird thing we have as we get
towards the end of the season 30th
anniversary stuff's gonna stay
theoretically yeah i mean the free stuff
we don't know how long that stuff's
going to say but zur's warehouse is
going to be there for a little bit
but late
season of the loss like astro alignment
like okay you're the you're the person
who's going to make after alignment
if this was a normal season you're gonna
make the activity that's gone in three
months
yeah so you can see they reused assets
they reused the blind well and then they
put some different mechanics in there
which is fine but it can't be
it's hard to expect something like
proving grounds or like a new strike
because you know that theoretically
should stay but you don't know expunge
and override like having their different
like override was used but expunges we
weren't getting those but we got
shattered realm and sadly that's going
away so it's weird to see these like
late year editions that also leave
quickly which is interesting
um yeah i mean fusions are an absolute
blast we talked a lot about crucible
it's crazy
um
but overall yeah we talked about
crucible almost more than anything else
besides how much like me my thing was
the metroidvania of like what's the new
thing this week what's the new things
that you can unlock and find and that
was the piece for me that probably made
me the most mad when i started this
season
outside of the story which i'm with you
guys when you go to chapter seven of
eight you get in chapter eight you know
is six four months away that's the most
frustrating of this entire thing because
the momentum is gone you guys have both
said it when we get to that final reveal
like
february say eight if it's two weeks
before so i don't know when it's gonna
be
i don't know when it's time i mean i'm
guessing i don't know some people are
i'm not saying you're right yeah it's
like people say like hey when it comes
back in january i'm like why like it's
in my head it's got to be close because
if you do in january then you leave
another like six weeks of nothing or
like four weeks of nothing so they're
probably going to do it close so it's
like
that's one of my big complaints before
we get to the 30th is the storytelling
needs to complete
in a row finish the story and you can do
it later the final chapter hasn't been
printed my butt um things been written
six months ago
and that's the annoying part for me is
that delay in the finale when you're
already almost here especially with the
preview we have for witch queen
that's not gonna build the hype as they
hoped
and it's not gonna work quite the same i
wish they would do the story let's set
like and then find some way it's like if
the story has an issue
one more thing do an almighty moment
they have the systems in place to do it
have that be the go into the chamber and
see the chrysalis bust open have her
like go steal the ahamkara egg and like
fly out
see some cool animation like that that
everyone can go see once but on the
other side you don't need the
delay just to get like what's probably
gonna be going back in after alignment
with a twist is probably all that's
gonna be
and that's gonna be a letdown by the
time you get there and that's
unfortunately i don't like seeing that
because the story was as you guys said
was like yeah freight train momentum
hits a wall and i just hate seeing that
so i mean
to be nice even though we we all agreed
it was handled not the greatest and you
know it's just you know we don't like
the way it was executed you know this is
both both examples of these delays were
as a result of major expansions being
delayed when they were supposed to take
the place of said delay right so we we
try to cover 18. yes
yeah exactly try to understand it but i
agree it just it's such a punch to the
gut because it's just like damn like
we've
we got no momentum yeah you know we're
just waiting so long you know for it but
you know they they understand i don't
know what i guess my my question is i
guess like what could they do
when they know they have a delay and i
guess the
i mean if we transition into it i was
like for me whether it's a 12-week
season or a six-month season the story
beats should be completed in succession
if you're gonna do a weekly story beat
don't do a mid-season finale with one
more episode do all eight episodes and
then next season well and you can if you
want to do like a live moment if you
want to do a little blip at the end cool
if you want a little more transition
which actually would like because chosen
to splicer was like
not connected
right so it's like if you want a little
connection moment for some reason or a
little teaser that's fine but eight
episodes of the eight episode season
need to be in eight weeks not seven and
then week four the question is why do
you think they are intent
on not giving us that right what like
because i agree with you right they they
should conclude the story right because
we're gonna wait anyway right so
conclude the story
the only thing i can think of is that
they're trying to build up this fake
hype again for witch queen well exactly
that's something they don't before i
would say that you don't that's what you
are correct i'm gonna bet that you are
probably correct they're hoping that
last two weeks of the season
hey log back in see how the season ends
then they'll drop the trailer then
they'll drop the twab the hype's going
into the next season
right the trailer and the swab are going
to do it anyway
right see that's where i'm with you
that's right i'll just
need to like hey here's a reason to log
back in like the trailer trailer's gonna
do it people have taken their break
period even if you're gonna be like well
now you gotta go pop back in for five
seconds to see a little thing and then
you're done again get it all done then
do a trail and be like oh cool i'm ready
to come back next season maybe i'll log
in check a couple boxes but like it's
you don't have to like that's the for me
it's like yeah you get those with you
and then if you want to do a little
teaser for the season you want to do
like a little bonus if you're like
whatever but that story needs told start
to finish in the weeks that are
connected no no epilogue break crap for
the main story that's my main
one of my main arguments i travel i
think they're fearful
of lost engagement so much
that they keep sticking to this old
model of all right so then you know two
more weeks before
then we'll we'll we'll we'll conclude
the savithune saga and then it'll lead
right into which queen and we'll get
that hype but i'm kind of with e i'm
curious what you feeling try because i'm
kind of like you know with e now that i
i think they've they don't need to do it
anymore like they they couldn't conclude
it right let's say they would have
concluded it
a couple weeks back
we would have had the story and then we
would have had this 30th anniversary we
all still would have played we're always
still logged in
and then
once which queen trailer and ready to go
ready to go but what do you think like
do you still or do you disagree do you
think like yo they're fine doing it this
way based on what their analytics and
their metrics show um
i think the reason they're doing it has
more to do with book ending the season
than it does with building hype or
anything like that okay because
i think that they want the season to
have a beginning and then a story that's
told over time but they can't do more
than a week because
that's like too long to wait for the
next episode of something but then
practically speaking
they can't do a season so quickly that
they're changing a new season every 12
weeks right or every every eight weeks
or however long it is that they've been
doing the story so i think um
i think it has to do more with
practicality like
why are you helping marisov and why are
you talking to crystals and doing all
the stuff that you do with the season if
the season ends after the 10th week and
there's like no time for you to catch up
so they kind of need to hold the end
until the end of the season right that
way they can go okay this this event
marks like the end of season of the lost
and now the season of the witch queen is
started or whatever the heck they're
gonna call it so i think it has to do
more with like practicality of their
game and like book book ending the
season it it's such a tough
thing to do because
they don't have enough
content to make six months with every
every week a new thing and also i don't
think that would work i think you'd get
exhausted of every single week yeah
anticipation and building up and having
to like grind a thing that would that
would just suck
um so i think that they have this dead
space to let other players catch up who
can't log on every week because there's
probably still some people out there
catching up on on the storyboard so do
you think it's more like worry of
spoilers for the people who can't catch
up because theoretically
if you could play all eight weeks we'll
see then okay so if you're worried about
if people don't log in early they can
still log in on week 10 get all eight
weeks of the season and get the story in
one chunk if they wanted to that way if
it was without the bookend but
right but then they don't have a reason
why it's still season of the lost
like if you if you're spending five
months of season the loss with the story
over and marisov done and savithun taken
care of then it's not really seasonal
lost right they want it to have an
ending and i get that like the final
event of that season should happen at
the final week of the season but the
problem with that model is that they
don't have enough content to fill in a
six-month five-month season even a
three-month season i think is probably
more than they should do just because
people aren't gonna stick around and
listen to you know 40 episodes of a soap
opera just to get to the ending you know
that's just way too much to ask for the
player so i think it has to do more with
the practicality of like what a season
is versus their bandwidth and ability to
actually pump up content so i don't know
if it's a if it's even a solvable
problem but i do agree it's super
annoying uh as a player to have to wait
that long and for
uh
you know for all those things to happen
but um it's the way they've chosen to do
it i kind of think they should wrap it
up and
i don't know if the seasonal model even
makes sense for destiny
mm-hmm
to be honest with you that's another
thing it's another game that's a debate
we've had all year that's a big idea
they should just they should just do
content releases
like why does it have to be a whole
season about it or like you're doing a
thing it just but well we know we got
four more seasons at least for which
queens so it continues for another year
i think they're gonna continue and i
think they're still not gonna take away
levels from the artifact which they
should so stupid
yeah i just there's so there's so many
things about the seasonal model and
destiny that
i get why they're doing it because it's
the thing with game live service games
live services they're all doing seasons
now but i kind of wonder like does
destiny need to do it or can they just
release updates and update you know you
get it all at once and it's there or
they they put it out over the course of
eight weeks and then it just sort of
sits there and doesn't get anything on
top of it but i feel like they want the
season to be living and they want their
devices for the beginning and then you
to go through and play all in the middle
and then at the end of the season there
to be this finale at the end right
before the new season starts and i get
that need i get why they're doing it it
just unfortunately means that those of
us who are really on top of our [ __ ] and
play every week have to wait and it's
awkward for us but yeah maybe this is a
one-time thing maybe it'll just be like
a four-week wake in the future because i
really think the problem is
a three-month wait feels awful
a five-month weight feeling i mean like
i think maybe this is okay the epilogue
hasn't wasn't as bad but it still wasn't
great to me
because that was
i think splicer literally had epilogue
on it or one of those or chosen did
it's still
again as i think you described it well
it's like a problem that doesn't have a
great solution
because they want
but the only problem with the way the
stories have been told this season is
there hasn't been a great connection
it's not like season of the chosen and
kyle's story and the way that wraps up
tied into mythrax at all
so when you finish season of the chosen
and if you want to bookend it it's a way
to wrap a season sure
but
there's not like hey season title does
this thing
and you know kyle
passes crosses by like title is like
having a meeting with zavala and also
mythrax walks up with a white flag like
hey can we talk like that doesn't happen
to say like uh
that's cool that the transitions and
again same thing splicers myth wrecks
put a bow on that and then now savith
now sabathoon had a little more tie in
there which was better because
expunge and override and those pieces
had her little text in the corner and
then now savithoon but it wasn't still
like the best tie aquario was there a
little bit but again it's not like this
true tie over connection so again i if
the
if the connections got better it would
make more sense for the epilogue but
still like
a month delay just to get the final
chapter doesn't sit great but at least
if there was a connection it would i
wish it was like most of it's told and
then like the connection like the
epilogue was truly like an epilogue like
here's your story climax ending finish
epilogue you know it'd be like four
weeks later this is where we are and
that's how it goes almost like if you
were reading a book where it's like six
months later whatever yeah type thing
the key for i'm sorry no it's like
that's just it's
it's the more travis talked about it the
more i understand why it is a weird
issue
but
so far they haven't proven to me that
it's necessary to move that epilogue so
far until it connects better i guess
that's where i'm at
yeah where i'm at is to keep for me is
going to be 2022
barring no more delays right if we have
we're assuming right which queen debuts
which should have debuted 2021 in in the
fall so
barring now which queen now launches
the end of 2022 whatever said next
expansion is that light fall
yep yes
so if light
drops so lightfall is what is it
scheduled right now what is it if you go
a year later than which queen then
theoretically it's february of 23 but
that's just speculation
that's speculation right so the question
is gonna be do we think we would get an
expansion at the end of the year right
we most likely we're going to assume no
because witch queen got pushed back
right no like um they if they're doing
four seasons they wouldn't shrink a
season if anything they'd have extra
length if they'd need to delay witch
queen
i think it would only get farther away
i think lightfall will come out
in
fall of 2023
wow
that far wow yeah i think wow because
because they're gonna launch this witch
queen and they're gonna immediately have
a ton of stuff to do and i just can't
see lightfall coming out a year later
that's crazy to me i think it'll
probably be like an 18-month rotation so
do you think the seasons will be longer
then
i think they'll do the exact same thing
they've done this one where the seasons
are normal length and then a big delay
yeah so pretty much we're off katie off
the norm the traditional cadence okay
because they don't have to be right okay
no
i think it'll be 18 i think it'll be 18
months between releases
i mean for them to get away from crunch
for them to get away from christ
yeah i mean that's kind of one of those
things too it's like you got quality now
of course you have stuff coming out
about bungie we talked about that
previously where
you know they're trying to be a better
employer but again there's a lot of
pieces to that puzzle much like on top
of the equality and everything else that
they're trying to work on it's like
working conditions and everything still
a lot of people working from home
that type of stuff so again if you say
18 months and you do it again that's a
point to where it's like hey whatever
lightfall is
whatever happens in season 16 17 18 19
right please don't do this again that's
all i'm saying season 19 story i don't
need that six month epilogue for e in
fairness it's not like they purposely
did it they they they they planned to
drop which queen in no no i i guess
but again as also travis is saying
like they'll do it again do you it was
like do you think they can get back to
that annual cadence
or
do you even want them to i'll be honest
for them or uh
the more i listen to travis talk about
it
the more i agree that they control their
own destiny in the way
they're going to do things and to find a
point on it
yeah i think traditionally yeah right
like that
traditionally
we have to i have to mentally break
myself from the mindset that every
september is when a new destiny
expansion happens right they are now the
runners of their own ship and now with
which queen pushed back to february
that's that's a big that's a huge change
we're getting a major expansion in
february has never really happened that
changes the course of the rest of the
timeline so
all bets are off now right so and i'm
with trav i can't ex at least for 2022 i
cannot expect them to give us another
major expansion release afterwards
completely
it won't be less than a year february
would be the soonest i'd expect it
but again i think it'll be i think it'll
be summer closer to september yeah now
now scarole shout out to our
i think maybe maybe what would solve
your problem ebontos
is if they just did an eight-week story
and they had an epilogue and then that
week before the new thing came out was
more of a prologue to the upcoming
season rather than a closer to the
previous to the previously i totally
would support that the seas the season
prologue to the next season i think that
would that would solve it
the question would be though i like
what's carol saying in the chat shout
out to
you know is that
because of all you know which queen
being delayed in february if february
ends up becoming if they're able to
maintain it if they're able to
maintain this schedule in this cadence
of content release if february becomes
the new expansion release as opposed to
the traditional september so it's an
annual february like a spring
expansion release that would be
interesting to see if they able to do
that if they did that i guess we would
all know that crimson days is dead for
good
oh yeah
yeah it definitely is we're like we're
launching witch queen with crimson days
right out of the gate
it's not looking good for crimson days
this year and i don't i don't think
it'll be looking good for crimson any
year if february becomes the regular
release
for the crimson
well uh there's one more piece i wanted
to get to regards to other games the
30th anniversary we've talked a lot
about it recently um but that was kind
of
but that was kind of the shot in the arm
that we got to fill this gap not story
related but
cool exotics gal horn forerunner grasp
of avarice a cool actually got a dungeon
in halo weapons the heirs of eternity
i know paul had his dares of eternity
finally got a sword moment there the
grind for the forerunner catalyst is
just exorbitantly long
um yeah but overall 30th anniversary for
a lot of people i would
say some people question the value i
guess this is my main question the value
of 30th anniversary is it worth it
because what you are paying for is
ornaments gallohorn and grass because
dares halo 4runner free so theoretically
what was advertised about it is half
free
so do you pay the 20 the 25
do you guys feel the 30th anniversary is
worth the 25 say the real price
for somebody who you know averaged joe
um i'm late to the party because you
guys did obviously your last word you
guys got to talk more about stuff and
i'm just now catching up so i'll just
say this before i get into that question
um i just finally did shout out to dj
who's in the chat dj oral shout out to
um
mitch it was oh man it was it was it was
fun gra i finally did grasp
i really enjoyed it where do you rank it
very tough um
oh man this is tough i it is
the story is absolutely hilarious
right the the whole
[Music]
yeah after my loot
i had to get rid of that when i threw a
guardian down a shoot and do a grenade
on them and you know say like that the
jokes of it was hilarious um
the mechanic of the whole greeds you
know get the ingrams point into the
thing
you know you could play tricks on your
friend by hitting switches and stuff
like that the final encounter and then
um
shooting across the
breaking the wall was fun you know i'm
saying doing um shooting across the
different aspects of the fall and stuff
i don't know if i have it as my number
one
i like it
i don't know if i have it over
um i still think the champion is uh the
one in um that you go to prophecy
yeah prophecy i still think is the
champion i love the prophecy f boss
fight
and i still think the mechanics of
prophecy building the room with light
and dark cube room and yeah i still i
still have that as a better
experience but
this is a fun experience
this is tough i don't it's a fun thing
but i don't you know what it reminds me
it's the wrath of the machine conundrum
whereas something
how high do you rate something because
it is fun
versus why do you want to play video
games
true
true because they're fun that's from uh
acg it's fun factor
shout out to acg i think it it's it's a
lot
all i mean to your answer your original
question i think so far it has been
worth it for me the the um the the 30th
anniversary for me i am biased though
you throw halo weapons
oh yeah it's like but like clearly we
all like destiny
yeah like the halo thing got me bro like
the the the forerunner the then you got
the the the auto i mean the pulse rifle
that's literally the br
like a union they made a unique pulse
rifle archetype for it yeah like i i i
feel it is you know what i'm saying now
there's a return that stuff is free
that's the truth
you're right you're right
pretty well he said uh hold on fine
pricing scheme is all over the place i'd
pay it again but i understand why
someone might have a problem with pretty
much a single dungeon for 25 dollars
yeah because again you're talking about
halo halo halo i was like everybody got
that then you're like do you want
gallohorn and do you want a dungeon
ornaments or ornaments like you get like
the full ornament set then you can earn
another ornament set if you have the
30th anniversary that stuff you can get
so you can get a lot of ornaments which
value-wise those suckers are expensive
anyway so then you're getting a dungeon
for like ten dollars
yeah so it's always that like where do
you value all the pieces that was all
yeah i mean
i get i get it i think that it's worth
it for me that's all i want to say for
me i really enjoyed that dungeon i i
thought it was really fun i thought
galley coming back was cool i i like
dares of eternity a lot i think it's
absolutely hilarious it's a game show
it's funny you know what i'm saying it's
it's a cool activity they had fun with
their
yeah i mean i'm curious guys what you
think i'm really
enjoying the content a lot that's where
i'm at
uh
yeah my perspective on the situation is
on principle i never
i try to never take price into
consideration when i'm evaluating if
something is good or not and the reason
for that is partially because they beat
it into my head when you learn to write
for ign is that money is not a reason to
review something better or worse neither
is the circumstances in which a game is
created right like if a game is made by
a smaller team it doesn't make it a
better game because it's made by a
smaller team right it just means that it
was made by a smaller team and the
reason i think it's important to not
worry about value or money is because
a the price of it doesn't make it better
right if it's cheaper it doesn't mean
the dungeon is suddenly better because
it was cheaper it just means that it was
they charged less money for it and two
money means different things to
different people some people have lots
of money and it's not a big deal to pay
25 and for some people 25
is like the difference between you know
food that day or not you know or
or maybe they're making rent and so it's
it's way too complicated to get into it
so what i try to view is
is the content that they're selling fun
is the content that they're selling
worth your time yeah i would say the
dungeon and gallerhorn are both fun and
worth your time
and so therefore it's up to you to
decide true price is worth those things
all i can do is give you a
recommendation on the content itself and
so the content itself is good um
the free content is also good um but
again it being free doesn't make it
better or worse apex is a free game some
would say it's a fantastic shooter that
is free nerf legends is a 70 game and
some people
mostly me would say that that game is is
hot garbage fun at all so um so yeah i i
i would say uh
it's up for you to decide the money but
for me the content that that i paid for
was really high quality and i'd probably
pay it again i definitely would i mean
i'm i'm a destiny center yeah so i was
like i mean i got a part of the you know
which queen pack so i mean mine was 20
bucks was a little bit cheaper i get a
dungeon i get a couple ornament sets i'm
like sure i know and that's the thing i
actually did when making this list i
posted on twitter twitter and i go
through and i look what does a year of
destiny look like
100 bucks for the next year and if we
look back through and everything we just
got done talking about for an hour and a
half
came with the 80 pack and then now with
the 30th anniversary that's the 30th
plus which queens year 100 for
everything we got over the course of a
year as you said some games are 70 and
don't have nearly this much now is this
the type of game that everybody likes
are there issues with it absolutely sure
we want to pull our hair out with armor
synthesis there are moments 100 percent
get it but
overall like the value of the game if
this is a game that you have fun with
it is a very good value in scaro no nerf
legends is not game of the year it is
what is the opposite of game of the year
it needs that award
yeah the razzies yeah
the razzies yeah
it's a good one so no i was just going
to say just to put a quick kind of
either prediction or wants for you guys
as we wrap up this year for
which queen 2022
and also just where do you see which
queen's year ranking in the seven in the
eight year spectrum of destiny predict i
want to go for prediction now because
we'll do a 2022 prediction and kind of
recap where do you see the year of witch
queen ranking in the spectrum of
destiny's years
look at you yeah
what that's a good question
i think i i think it'll be i think it'll
be worse than in my book i think it'll
be worse than the taken king worse than
forsaken but i think it'll be better
than all the other ones and i don't
really think that's that hard of a bar
to cross to be honest with you yeah
rise of vanilla destiny let's not even
talk about that uh rise of iron is good
but it has like four story missions and
it didn't really change a whole lot
about the game uh just added some some
good content
destiny to vanilla i actually like more
than most people it's probably number
four for me but uh no redwater was like
the longest campaign i think we've ever
had
yeah i like that
that campaign and i i loved it didn't
mind a lot of stuff like trials of the
nine i i thought was you know obviously
double primaries was a problem but yeah
that was like to the mode um and then uh
after that we've got what um what was
the next full year wasn't it curse of
osiris that was part way through
four seconds desperately forsaken
i think it'll probably better but they
they have mentioned that they can't do
the
the scale of forsaken yeah
the taking king is just hard to beat in
my book i don't think that they'll be
able to do it just because it's such
high quality but i think it'll be better
than like shadow keep for sure but
beyond like for sure for sure all that
stuff
uh so yeah i think it'll probably be the
third best would be my guess that's like
such a pessimistic thing to say the
future's bright i think it'll be the
third best yeah right
but uh but yeah i think that that's
probably where they'll land which isn't
bad what was your second best after
taking king
craft uh forsaken
okay yeah all right so we kind of got
the same ranking um
yeah i mean
that's about a reasonable prediction i
think that you can make i i agree i
think that
as much as i want it to be the greatest
thing of all time you know that kind of
thing you know they've they've outright
said we're not getting
taken king level forsaken level
expansions so
that kind of puts a kibosh on that not
to say that the quality is going to be
garbage or anything like that it's just
the the sheer scope that's all i'll say
so um
yeah i would think definitely i i think
i'm literally right in pocket with
everything traffic i don't
i don't think it's gonna be
it could ri maybe right the only way it
could rival forsaken
that raid
and the lead up in the campaign
gotta be like god tears storytelling
like something would also need a secret
location yeah they've got to do
something that we just did not expect
they blow our mind or something that
we've complained about
and they actually execute and we go oh
okay budgie you know what i'm saying so
they got a shot at it i mean we all saw
the devs yelling on twitter bungie
you know they're clearly excited about
something you know in the future but
is that it we will see right you know
kind of thing but from i think a low end
expectation at the very minimum it will
be
better than beyond light and better than
shadow keep i'm confident in that
confidence gonna be better than that and
i just want to see the execution i want
to see
is she truly
worthy of that villain title that we've
given oryx right that that's that's
really the question for me yeah because
and the question is
i don't want her like he says like i
don't want her blasted out after we do
it mission fight
strike dead yeah we're gonna airlock her
what if we what if we killed her in the
in the first mission
how much would you guys lose your mind
if it was the opening mission you were
going to see upstream stop me on the
street i'm just going to be like
all right screw this
i'm kind of talking myself into it now
now i kind of want that to happen
that would be the only thing nobody
would suspect no one would have that on
their bingo card that she dies in the
opening mission and somebody else's
zebra wrath is actually like uh the main
daddy something like that what kind of
it's just the darkness
or it's just the darkness
is the real villain
on that one yeah look it it will it will
tell us from a native standpoint we do
complain that they we that stuff is
predictable they just throw us this
curveball we'd be like yo
mind blown it was a ruse all along zebra
rat yo
damn it
damn it i said it as a joke and now i
kind of i'm hoping for a pining that
this is the case listen i either have to
kill her on the first or second mission
we're gonna kill her and then she's
gonna have the light and she's gonna
then you're gonna see her resurrect or
something is
so she's gonna have the light and
resurrect so right so that's it just the
transition i want the narrative beast to
be good i'm very curious about crafting
very curious about that want to see how
that ex yeah see what where they go
because the prismatic recaster and
umbrellas are out of the helm yeah but
let me give it to you what what's your
prediction on it
for a year of content if you go full
year
taken king is a great expansion
but we had a lot of downtime in that
year before rise of iron yes so it was
like the expansion was good
if witch queen can
even
scratch
at a close factor of like the expansion
of right of um taken king
if they keep with the storytelling that
they're doing in these seasons and if
they keep building like cool things like
pressage and the campaign is sick can we
have
honestly like i think taken king as a
year won't hold a candle to which queen
if they can't deliver on a campaign and
stories that build you're talking about
the whole year i literally said years
that's why you guys sorry my no my mom
cut off my headset kept disconnecting i
still stick with my prediction
so for a year of content for me
which queen theoretically could beat
them all
if we have stories because i mean if you
go back to like
forsaken we had seasoned the drifter we
had season of the forge we had season of
opulence which i know is pretty high
but it depends do you like stories do
you like activities where do you fall on
all the stuff
if they can keep the stories the voice
acting that type of stuff going kind of
new unique perks fun exotics
and then somehow like have like the
pressages and the other pieces paired
with like
couple dungeons couple like another raid
coming back it could be one of the best
years we've ever had i think it's
possible
if but granted the big question is how
do we handle savithune is it what travis
wants and this is like our our
enemy we talk to and interact with all
year long or it's like kind of an enemy
but kind of this weird antagonist not so
much the villain we kill in the raid or
if she dies in the middle of the first
mission is going in the trash like it's
one of those it'll be in the bushes for
your guy's sake
um
so yeah the big question is like i want
to know how that campaign pays out
campaign plays out and that'll be my big
one i think mostly so
i will be very curious because it has
potential i think for a full year of
content to do
a lot it has potential for sure but as
you said yeah you got crafting you got
glaive there's a lot of potential
but i think we've said this half the
year there's also a lot of weight on
this if it can live up to what people
want at this point which
hopes are probably too high for it as it
is yeah we show off for sure so kind of
the final thing that i want to touch on
with you guys complete shift at this
point we got a short time we gotta let
cognito get to uh pick up lady cognito
or mother cognito i guess
ladies
not lady um
but mama cog the mother of ninjas she's
a man
the mother of the mother of ninjas
that was good yeah
so what i wanted to ask you guys um
we play a lot of other games
you get we talk a lot about destiny but
we actually tend to play a lot of other
games throughout the year between down
times and things like that um so i
wanted to ask you guys if you can kind
of make this i'm going to do this and
the most anticipated that you know about
for 20 like what are you looking for
um top three to five games however big
of a list that you can kind of get out
in a few minutes what are your top-ish
games
for
um kind of 2021
and
if you want to do just like start
towards the bottom do a couple and work
your way up or if you guys just want to
knock out a list
cog if you got anything you just want to
get off your chest i can probably tell
you travis is number one anyway so i
don't even know if you need to ask him
so so we're going to start off with top
games of 2021. top games in 2021 just
you know three to five top ones wherever
you want if you even want to rank them
it's up to you just like
what do you yeah i mean what have you
played why are they up there for you for
me
i'll start kind of towards the bottom um
forgotten city was absolutely amazing
for me oh my god so good yeah i still
need to play that that's on my list that
came out of nowhere it that is to me is
how you do
a time loop game like 12 minutes tried
to do something
and
it was just a respectful of time with
that um
i gotta admit i think it's halo infinite
for me bro i think you're taylor
infinite but it's not it because it's i
love you yeah i love you too brother
i love you too bro it's
first of all doing the campaign or
heroic for me was the sweet spot of the
perfect difficulty where every boss
fight felt like a challenge is it
perfect no of course there's some you
know little issues here and there what
is your body talk so yeah yeah as far as
storytelling and
i just had so much fun with that game
like that like it
i didn't know if they would transition
to the open world as well as they did
and i thought it i thought it was i
thought it was done well
i love the characters i love the ashram
situation and i'm not gonna spoil but
yeah it was i i felt very strongly about
that i enjoyed every minute towards the
end of that game i really did and the
multiplayer
sorry that's the it's the best right now
it's just it's the most balanced i think
it's got the best gun play best gun play
best balance most fun most it's it's not
even close it the king is back it's back
i'm just i have to say it it's just what
it is so that's the two i could think of
off top right now i know i'm forgetting
a couple of things i know
i want to say disco but disc already
came out
and um
you played
so yeah yeah oh guardians guardians is
fire guardians was amazing i was a
sleeper on my list yeah those are three
right now i could think of right now if
i i'll let you guys go if anything else
comes comes up to me but don't have this
right now where are you halo infants my
number one
no swords or horizon five
[Music]
after that would probably be
marvel guardians of the galaxy yeah and
then after that psychonauts 2 which i'm
actually not done with but damn it yeah
i got to get done with it other games
you should go and play this year that
were super good resident evil village
death loop
um oh that's not known as these super
good metroid dread that's why it was yes
um
forgotten city you already gave a shout
out for but that one was super good
tales of a rise
yes
matt eagle's hard for that too
uh knock out city yeah
it's not funny knockout city yeah we'll
sleep i gotta see he's probably on my
top 10 games this year that was like
yeah i know you raped about that one
yeah i was i'm a stan for that one um
and then what else can we count mass
effect trilogy because we played a lot
with it
i never count remasters that's true
but
yeah those are those are probably my top
my top games this year uh that i think
everybody should try to make time for um
yeah yeah i mean i've kind of got a list
some honorable mentions there's a lot i
missed like stuff i missed like
forgotten city absolutely still got to
play the halo campaign that's another
one in psychonauts like those are three
big ones
i've missed that i really want to play
um
as for
i haven't done this in a complete i
literally finished guardians last night
at 1 o'clock in the morning so those of
you guys that were in my twitch chat
finished it last night that game is
prettier better voice acted
um character models pretty worlds like
then it ever had any like
respect like chance it should have been
i don't love the combat
yeah and that's like the point for me
that doesn't keep it as high but
everything i almost wish the combat
would have almost been
almost like more on rails just so the
story could have been like lived through
because the combat and the abilities are
kind of fun for me but it's like
depending on if like you know you trip
and fall then you gotta repeat a segment
or something it's like right moments
like that and it's
but everything else about like i'm
sitting there like
ratchet is just like going a rocket is
going through his thing and then it's
like all the the story beats when
when you have to towards the end what
you have to do to break somebody out of
something which you guys are like all me
and chad i'm just like dagger to the
heart twist i'm like damn this is i was
like oh this is about to get rough yeah
you need to you just need a hug so
no like that game it's worth the yeah
it's like you know 15 16 hours whatever
it takes to get through the story the
combat's fine but everything else in
that one playing it on my new monitor
god it's just gorgeous so beautiful game
beautiful beautiful game so i mean that
one um returnal is
i don't know if it's my number one but
it i haven't like solidified my list but
return all did something for me this
year that was
somehow a bullet hell roguelike
third-person
shooter and the deeper you got into it
the crazier it got the last biome just
kind of blew me away
then when you figured out more about
like this little lingering kind of like
vague story and it's kind of like got
that like un
unclear souls like story but enough
where you kind of get it it's return was
special for me because i started it
set it down for something and then i
still wanted to know so much and it
kicked my ass enough i still wanted to
pick it back up
and then actually like i wasn't sure i
was going to get it and then it's like
you finally make that next hurdle so
that was really good grime is my gotta
be like my
i know can't
keena
is like a sony indie but it had a can
cana is it canada yeah
i think it's kenna kenna oh i've heard
it like four different ways but yeah
told us how to do it and i forgot how to
pronounce it was beautiful like i want
to see their second game because that
was a fun game and harder than it should
but grime for a tiny little like four or
five person little team and a cool
composer the music when that thing hits
the weird places that story went and the
combat was for me like really cool in
the exploration grime was like really
high
um death loop
i had so much fun in that game
maddie hates it which kills me when i
listen to him but i haven't played
dishonored so in fairness i don't have
that point of reference i just had so
much fun in death loop listening to
both of them go back and forth like it
was yeah just the two main voice actors
the crap they gave each other the way
things were delivered and i was like and
there's some stuff detracting from it
but honestly it's like return is
probably maybe my number one just
because of so it was unique for me to go
through something like that
um it takes two i played the whole thing
through with my la my wife and it's like
i don't know if i've ever played a game
with my wife or finished one with her so
that one's very special it the story was
cheesy but the fact that we played it
together was cool
um i wanted kind of an honorable mention
to outriders
because my experience in outriders
was honestly like a blast i had like the
week and a half that i played it
i had so much fun so many things for
looter shooters i'm like please learn
from outriders and then they still come
back with transmog and slap it in
destiny's face like certain things about
that
and then to finish my year on guardians
and then i played metroid dread and as
somebody who loves
that style it's so good
so it is like tight the progression just
like here's a new thing here's the new
thing here's this cool thing here's this
like i think i only found like 40 of the
stuff and i still finished it i didn't
want i didn't care 100 because i was
trying to but i was like
i remember metroid super metroid being
one of my favorite snes games and this
basically solidified as to why
because nintendo may take four and a
half years and painfully take their damn
sweet time to put bluetooth turn on
bluetooth in the switch and i wanted to
kill him for that but the fact that i
turned on bluetooth and put one earbud
in and played this thing and metroid is
a polished tight complete game that like
the animations are just like it's just
so well done oh yeah so
i was like i don't know where my list
solidifies yet but there's
there's not like a god of war or last of
us or i mean halo infinite for you guys
is that for i just haven't played it yet
yeah it's like
i haven't played that yet so that's why
i was like and i'm not as attached to it
as you guys but for me
there were some amazing games that are
duking it out and it's hard because i
had a fun with a lot of them so yeah i
wanted to add you made me remember i
have to add
outriders towards the bottom of the list
only because the game if a game is as
broken as it was as launched still gets
me to want to play it as much as i still
played it it's a testament to the game
because that game literally did
everything in its power for me not to
like it and i still have destiny year
one yeah it was destiny year one but it
was just like but like he said the
quality of life these customizations
like everything that we're like destiny
please take notes this is how
you do things you know on quality of
life for a looter shooter
i have to give it that and i i still i
still had a ton of fun and i'm curious
to see where they go continue on for it
actually i got to play the new content
what is it horizons whatever knew what
they did oh
there were like four expeditions but the
stories yeah but i'm going to try it i'm
getting
a couple quality life changes there
mostly yeah all right yeah it's like so
my list i know got long and a little
extra but it's good there's a there was
a lot of fun this year in games and it's
like and i still haven't solidified what
my top ones are going to be
and again it's like if i could iron out
like halo i'd be very curious where it
would fall but yeah it's like there's
a lot of stuff this year that was
there were some good surprises i will
say a couple letdowns though
bio mutant i never touched i was excited
for that
ballen wonderland i tried the demo and i
wanted to throw up
mario golf super rush was also a pretty
heavy letdown so those were a couple
letdowns uh top three games you're most
anticipated for in 2022 go and we have
one minute oh for me um
it's starfield i am
i am such a star
sci-fi nut and then i wanted to see you
want mass effect 4 but in bethesda world
no no i mean it's because it's not going
to be mouse it's not going to be mass
effect yeah this is this is going to be
like um
you know if this is even if it's skyrim
in space i'm going crazy you know what
i'm saying so i just want to know what
this thing the more i learn about it the
more excited i get so that's one
um horizon obviously looking phenomenal
or forbidden west i want to see what's
going on with that and surprisingly you
know i got my eye on that uh that elder
ring do look kind of fire i ain't going
for it oh my god if you're playing that
i want to watch if you play that i don't
want to watch dive in but i must please
it looks pretty cool but yeah that's it
for me right now as i just want to see
the rest of the year how it pans out but
what about you trash what you're
anticipating yeah yeah i think we're
probably going to have similar lists but
starfield for sure uh destiny 2 the
witch queen is online
excluding the obvious yes
yeah eldon ring is on my list also the
breath of the wild too is coming out
next year which is it though that's the
question
i think it will
pretty close said something where he saw
something about that or he's
i'm
personated
excited about um hogwarts legacy i don't
even really like harry potter but that
game has been fascinating me since the
yeah
again if that comes
yeah if it comes red fall
as well we haven't seen a lot of that
game but i'm pretty interested in that
um and then um
[Music]
gotham knights kind of
okay okay yeah yeah
okay
see what that's about yeah
a
few e
uh
i mean for me just
i'll be i'll be cliche as hell horizon
zero dawn god of war both of those for
me like god of war is my game of ps4 i
mean travis is like he doesn't
we are different minds on that one and
we know but that's fine um
but horizon is looking fantastic and i'm
so sad
but i mean nothing's gonna top my want
for another souls game from from from
software
and eldon ring for me is just it pains
me so much because of that delay it
absolutely kills me um because
as you you
who i know don't even care to touch
those ever are even slightly intrigued
so of course you know i'm like over the
top so
yeah elden ring horizon god of war yeah
i i i could play next year on a
playstation and be fine but
uh yeah those are those are my big ones
eldering i cannot wait and i just want
to get lost in that thing and i don't
i'm not going to have the time to do it
for a while a while and horizon the more
and more i see that thing is where it's
getting better and better like the way
that world looks is just going to be
looks phenomenal yeah absolutely the
snake like i'm like oh my god so no
that's gonna be crazy
uh but yeah four spoken final fantasy 16
like a couple other like discussions on
those i mean
and then of course like starfield if
they can do like a sci-fi world like
i've never
been as big into those but if that could
be like the one that pulls me into a
bethesda rpg bring it on like if that
thing can deliver then happy
so
well i know cogs gotta run um so we
gotta wrap this thing up thank you all
for being here for this one um
we probably will have an episode next
week because i think everybody will be
in town but this is like the end of 2021
wanted to wrap it up kind of a good
recap on the year of destiny because we
just kind of have a lull until we get
more on
which queen and things pick back up but
gentlemen it has been a pleasure of a
year i want to thank you both for
sharing the campfire with me sharing
stories making brand new friends out of
one of these so like literally the the
campfire expanded by one we brought up a
new log seat for him and um
travis it's been a pleasure cog as
always this is
what are we on our fourth year this now
basically
yeah four years of camp fire talk
didn't exist before me so i'd say the
first year it's been a pleasure
um but yeah
travis what about you
uh yeah you can you can find me on
ign.com uh my last review before i i
clocked out uh for 2021 was um
pray i don't remember praying like the
gods it was like the colossus pray for
the gods thank you yeah i gave a four
out of ten to end the year with a wet
fart uh
yeah don't play that game it's not that
good um
but yeah you can find my articles there
i'll be writing a ton of stuff for ign
next year i assume they've been using me
more and more um and then uh you can
follow me on twitter if you uh hate
yourself enough to do it
look uh it's been it's been tremendous
year man it's been it's been a fun year
we had a lot of fun
you know i just really enjoyed doing the
show i still enjoy doing it and um this
game is it's fun to track this is a one
thing about destiny i would love it i
hate it it is a very compelling
intriguing game to monitor and track and
it is so damn polarizing and i love it i
love it still love it it was cool to get
back to playing this week i love doing
this podcast trav has been a tremendous
addition holding the fourth down i call
him lord contrarian
but but he you notice i love it spicy
meatball takes yeah you love to see
different takes and he's spicy and he's
absolutely hilarious he we've been
holding this five place down and for a
long time and it's just fun to see the
growth of the show to see people come on
that haven't come on and just tell us
how much they enjoy doing the show with
us and and it's just cool man we had we
had tom warren this year we got some
tassie came back tassie travis with that
i was classic that's like our biggest
audio number as well the biggest also
yeah our biggest episode on every
platform the tassie and travis like
fight classic you know
the trial saga that was hilarious it's
just been a fun year and then let's see
let's be honest we got even got you know
some recognition by bungie and to see
the community
and people respect our opinions and come
to us and say hey you guys run a good
show that's dope you know so
love doing it next year's future is
bright we'll see how everything goes
with hopefully the world
doesn't get too more crazy and we can
all meet up in the flesh and everybody
can hang out again but um yeah it's been
tremendous here man happy new year to
everybody in the chat everybody please
enjoy themselves be safe
but uh what about you man thank you for
the intro nice little secret squirrel
intro that you pulled up that was very
cool gotta gotta throw a curveball in
the show every now and then uh no it's
it's been a pleasure between the channel
um
and just watching this thing grow the
number of people that we've been able to
meet and spend a couple hours with and
that's the thing about our show it's
like whether we get an hour or two it's
more than just like a 10 like a 10
minute interview or something we get to
spend an extended amount of time walls
tend to come down a little bit and we
get to see
some really fun conversations with some
really really great creators and just a
lot of friends of the show that we have
made over the course of the past year
and it's just been an absolute blast i
don't want to go too long because i did
my intro before so you guys are amazing
chat
audio listeners video listeners watchers
however you consume this show and
however it makes into your ears and eyes
thank you all for the support the growth
and everything um you guys have been
amazing and to my two co-hosts couldn't
do it without you and thank you guys so
much so for this episode number 178
happy 2021 guys be safe
probably stay at home
and yeah shout out in 2021 to hopefully
nice shaker but yeah uh have a very
happy and safe new year we will see you
in 2022 so for this episode and for 2021
it has been
the last word